Hey, Chuck, how are you?
Check if you're speaking, you're on mute.
Hey, sorry about that, Shashank. I am dealing with an escalation here, so I'm gonna have to be in my email at the moment. Bear with me.
Yeah.
No worries.
One second, I apologize. We gotta...
coordinate any on-site service with a vendor and they're hard to tie down. So I just wanted to make sure that that will, yeah.
No worries, this happens.
I totally agree, this happens.
Yep, I'm almost there. Sorry, honey.
We can Kip will need to.
Expand on ship, it's night to the service.
Sure, Evan.
County.
June 2nd.
I am almost done. I am so sorry.
So what season is it over there? Is it winter where you're at or do you guys have your summer coming up as well?
It's a hot summer, so yes, I would say in centigrade. Let me convert it to Fahrenheit as well, so that you're...
Hot summer.
Mm.
Very bad at this, so it's around 104 degrees Fahrenheit today, and...
Wow.
Yeah, and it's going to increase and go to what's expected is 122 degree Fahrenheit.
Ha ha ha!
So that is a lot hotter than it usually gets here. We might hit, you know, above 105 Fahrenheit sometime in like our high summer, but that's still a couple months away.
Summer is already here, May, June, and some parts of July. Usually are very hotter from July. We get monsoon. So we, it's more difficult because we have a lot of precipitation and.
Yes.
that that is really difficult to manage because if it rains 2 days and then it's the sun comes out, it's difficult to manage because it's neither cool nor hot and that would is simply very difficult to bear.
We have about 25 days left where we will get rain. Not every day guaranteed, but after that it will be very dry for three months or so.
Dry heat is still better, that's bearable, but when it's mixed with monsoon, it's pretty bad.
Yes.
We get that humidity too, because we are right on a river, so...
This is.
Yeah.
So, do you get like very hot, like 105 degrees with humid conditions?
Yes, we do. Not all the time, but I would say maybe about seven days a year, something like that. But we will have very, very humid conditions frequently. So
Okay, so for on our end, since the seasons are very well defined, so now it's summer, then it would be monsoon, usually with monsoon, it stays around for two months, July and August, sometimes it stretches to September as well. But yes, from September,
Mhm.
Spring starts where rains go off and then we start, the monsoon also goes off and the temperature starts to go down. And that's where it becomes cooler. And by October end or November starting, we start getting winters.
And that goes to...
Let me check what temperature it goes to. It goes to 40, 50 Fahrenheit.
Bob.
Yeah, a huge variation.
I was gonna say that is, uh, that's quite the range.
Yeah, so we get all four weathers here in North India. So in India, every region has a different weather, but in North specifically, we get these ranges.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay, well I'm all ready to go.
Okay, great. No worries. I hope the fire has been put out.
I did what I needed to. I don't think the fire is out, but we'll find out.
Okay, no worries. I won't take much of your time. And thanks for taking out the time. We know like last week you were busy. And today as well, you are busy, but you took out the time. Thanks for that.
Of course.
Yeah, so agenda stays the same. In last month, we can see Eva did give a good performance. She handled 122 calls, successfully completed 116 of them with an escalation rate of 4.9%, which is good. And this happened.
Yes.
Mm.
then she was already doing her training as well for the L1 task. So her training is going good, that's on track, and the productivity, yeah.
Bye.
We also had overall less calls last month, so there was, you know, less availability of tickets for her to close. So, you know, her 122 might not seem, you know, as high as some of the other peaks, but I was perfectly satisfied with her.
Oh.
performance. I also think her escalation rate is perfectly on track. Again, we're looking for a sub 10% there. And I know that the escalations I have reviewed from her have all been very thoughtful, right? There's always a number of steps that have been tried to intervene before the escalation that I think are appropriate. And that's really what I'm looking for, right?
Is that they they give it a shot, so...
Oh, that's great. Great to hear that. Let's go on to the numbers. So overall, 122. Average per day is 5.81. Overall, all were remote DSRS, 98.37%. 0.1% DSM and DSTR.
Mhm.
And when we see the breakdown, break fix for 77%, printing 31.97, scan to email 28.69, password reset 17.1, network disconnect 4.92, and other is 1.64. When we see her.
details of cases. That's 4.91% escalation that's under the benchmark.
Hello!
Average response time should be under 2 hours, so that was the 1.9 hours. So average repair time should be less than one hour, so that was again under control, 0.36. Travel time, yeah, we know like it should be under 2 minutes, sometimes takes 2 minutes.
Yes.
put in incorrect like one minute on that, but this is only for on-site. And average cost per equipment, that's also under control 1.03, so that's good. And most cases that she received was 95 out of 122, that's function stopped working. That's around 78%.
Kour.
Mhm.
Yep.
Yeah, so overall her performance is going good. And this is a holiday calendar. So next holiday that we can see is coming on 25th. So we have already got approval from other managers that on Memorial Day, Marco is closed.
Yes.
is correct. She is off on Monday and then she did get approved for her PTO. So she's going to be off all next week as well.
Yeah.
Okay, that's it from mine. Nothing else major from mine. Do you want to share anything else?
No, I will just say that I'm pleased to see her participating in the training on your side. You know, again, I feel like that can only help bolster her skills for us, even if, you know, some of it is not directly related. It makes her a better technician. And she's a really good candidate for it, right? So we should be seeing what her potential is.
Yep.
Yes, sure.
That's great.
Yeah, I'm very pleased.
Yeah, great, great to hear that that she is training the text as well. That's really great initiative from your end.
And this will help a group.
Yeah, well, I think she's got some experience under her belt at this point, right? And I want her to, you know, she's doing a lot of things right, and other people can maybe see that, right, that a certain way to approach something that didn't occur to them or something like that. So I'm excited to kind of share.
The expertise.
Great. Great to hear that, Chuck. And I'll take and I'll let you go back to controlling the fire. So thanks for your time and thanks for being available.
Yep.
Okay, yep. And if anything comes up between now and next meeting, just let me know. And otherwise, yeah, all things are going great here. I have not heard any more strategic discussions about, you know, what they, you know, see about this role evolving in the future. They're very
Sure, will do.
busy with their initiative. So as long as she is on my team, she's going to just be a full member and we're going to, you know, plan around her. Okay.
Sure, no worries. Thank you so much, Jack, for your time. Great. Have a great day. Thanks. Bye.
Okay.
Okay, thank you, sir. Bye-bye.